welcome back to these coffee hours so
today we have a really special guest we
have meet kevin paffraff and he's going
to tell us all about how much he's
making this year his tax write-offs why
he wants to buy a plane now everything
else about his business it's a really
interesting episode and he also gets
into uh his thoughts on the market stay
tuned if you want to see what's going to
happen in 2022 right now welcome back to
another episode of the iced coffee hour
the podcast has made more than 69
420 dollars to date i don't know exactly
how much but let's just get into talking
and drinking ice while drinking
hello thanks for coming on
it's great to see you as always welcome
and this time in california yeah it well
back to california i think i'm stuck
here forever i think last time we talked
about me wanting to leave and go to
vegas or something like that yes
what happened to that can you tell us
what yeah what i actually one of the
things i did is i just went to the
extreme and i'm like you know what i
should just move to puerto rico uh and i
should move there uh half half of uh the
week essentially go there for four days
work monday through thursday
and then just fly back and forth from
puerto rico it's like a six and a half
hour uh one way and just do that back
and forth
and i thought then my theory was i'll
just work really hard during those four
days do the four day work week and then
the other three days do zero work and
just spend time with lauren and the kids
or whatever
and then i would be mostly in puerto
rico if you start businesses there you
have to prove you have a bet a more
critical connection there which that's
probably one of the hard parts to do but
anyway you could try it and your tax
rate would go down to like four and a
half percent it would be tricky because
your family is here so there's like a
criteria of like 20 different things on
the forum like where you're registered
to vote what clubs you're part of where
your businesses are so we were thinking
of starting like five businesses there
like hiring dozens of employees and just
trying to check everything else off on
the list to kind of weigh the scale
more to that side but yeah in that in
that uh you know sort of thought
experiment i'm like my goodness let's
just say as an example you had 10
million dollars of income you would save
somewhere around four what point seven
five or whatever million dollars in
taxes doing that which is just like
insane right you'd be paying virtually
no taxes
uh but uh the problem with that is hey
you have to go back and forth which is
the pain in the butt uh and uh
number two
i i would not see my family for those
four days and one of the things that
we've
what i really like about working from
home is i make a video come outside and
i just wrestle with my kids or and go to
breakfast with lauren i would argue you
might actually see your family more that
was my belief if you did the three days
because you would see them all day
exactly and you wouldn't work
yeah could you actually though go a day
without posting a video i almost
believed that you would be like hey kids
one sec and then you'd get out your
phone and be like guys the market just
went crazy it's about to flip yeah that
was another issue too is that i i don't
know if i could actually and it sounds
weird like how could you not take a day
off so i did this thing where
gosh maybe five years ago uh my
father-in-law is you know kevin you you
owe yourself just take a day off and
just put your phone in a drawer just
don't ask just do whatever you want just
for a day take a day off do that every
week and so it became a thing like i'd
have a signature on my emails kevin
takes saturdays off to spend time with
family and so clients knew just just
leave me alone that day if you need
someone else you know to cover like call
somebody else who could cover me on
saturdays
and uh people really came to respect
that they're like oh that's so great you
spend time with family on on saturday i
did that for about a year and i realized
i was the most unhappy that saturday
overall oh
yeah i was like i was a grinch i wasn't
happy around being uh uh being around my
family all day because i felt
unproductive i wasn't getting anything
so yeah and and so i was actually losing
my mind so i was i was actually more
bitter to lauren and so saturdays were
worse than than when i would like work
and then hey lauren let's go to
breakfast because like yeah i feel great
lauren wants to you know lauren drop the
kids off for school and i'm like hey um
let's go to breakfast give me 25 minutes
i got to bang out a video
and i post that video and then right
after i post that video i feel like i
have like an hour and a half to just
screw around
because and then my anxiety starts
setting in again all right i gotta go
back to being productive
so i'm curious though have you talked to
a therapist about like the work
i don't want to call it an addiction
because i'm not a therapist but
because i have the the exact same thing
but have you but would you consider
talking to someone and like getting to
the root
i don't want to say the cause but like
what what's what's pushing you in that
drug have you always been like that
probably okay and and i probably should
i think the right answer is yes because
we so much characterize like mental
health as like oh if you see a therapist
you have a problem when that's not true
at all like we should all be talking to
somebody but we don't learn that in our
schools that we should talk to people
about how our mental health is but yeah
i definitely feel broken like there's a
lot of anxiety i feel like i've always
got to be working uh it's even even when
i came here you guys are setting up and
i'm like oh what's your little terminal
saying this is christmas
yeah it's so slow that's what i hate
like even weekends for me i keep looking
at cnbc and wall street journal i'm like
it hasn't updated like three hours
there's nothing there
so this obsession is mainly just in work
or has this been in every facet of your
life growing up uh well i mean it um it
could be video games as well uh when i
was really obsessed with uh playing
let's say world of warcraft or runescape
uh every
every opportunity well for example i'd
be in high school and i mean like this
class is so dumb i can just do what i
need to pass the test but i don't
actually need to be here so i would try
to find ways to leave my class uh we had
a lockdown campus though so i would
usually park where the construction site
was and none of the construction workers
cared and they had no security there so
i would go that way and then take my car
and drive just to go play video games to
oh because i'm wasting time in this
class i could be advancing i could be
leveling up oh
it really feels like that like you get
this anxiety same thing yeah it's it's
bad
and that's why i'm most happiest
when i just posted a video because i
feel like that's my opportunity to be
like okay i'm gonna go wrestle with the
kids i'll take them to the park we'll go
on a run
i feel the same way it's for me it's
always an hour after i post the video
and it does well yes if it does if it
does bad i'm thinking about it the
entire night how could i save the video
what can i change what sort of title and
even though i could be present in in my
mind i'm thinking like okay what what
title what title what title what could i
do what can i do oh yeah so yeah what it
does well that that hour afterwards
where there's nothing that i need to do
i think i just posted one that's
probably uh like a one to three
it is oh it's a one out of ten uh i
watched it oh it was a title it was uh
we are f to elon musk
but half of it i would say ninety
percent of the video has nothing to do
with elon musk just the first the first
minute kind of that sets the standard
for what we were talking about like
logic and and and research and reasoning
and then i wanted to give people some
value too like deep dive yeah but anyway
uh yeah so
that feels great you're right when a
video is doing really well and so that
gives me less anxiety for sure i agree
with you and if i have a bad video i'm
usually like all right i gotta find
another video to post and then you go to
the end of the day it's like kevin had
eight videos today
and they're all they were like nines and
tens and it's like oh finally one all
right so so for people that watch your
video
is it ever the more videos you post the
more you keep posting until you hit like
a one which is like a best performing
video so if you post eight videos a day
i'm like well that means the other
videos didn't perform that well so
you're posting more like if you have a
one right out of the gate
are you less inclined to make another
video that day yeah absolutely
absolutely so if days i post more uh
sometimes so i think there can be really
great content but sometimes the content
is is a little niched down so if i
really want to talk about rivian the
only people who care about rivien are
going to watch that right
and so those videos can be really
information dense i can do a fundamental
analysis and maybe they'll there'll be a
eight nine or ten well that it's like i
just put in the most amount of work for
a video that did the worst sometimes the
videos that you're just off the cuff
like honestly this one was just like
elon tweeted this and then it got me
thinking for 20 30 minutes whipped it
out 20 minutes and and it's doing great
sometimes those videos are just the best
the ones where it's just that
free flow of what you're thinking
compared to the fully researched ones
i've noticed but first we want to thank
our sponsor ritual hey guys the only
thing that is more intimidating than
these guns right here
are the confusing ingredients that are
in protein powders and the overall idea
of them and the truth is deep down at a
cellular level we all need protein and
it's not just about muscles rituals team
of scientists reimagined protein from
the ground up from how it's made to who
it's for and why it's needed the result
is a delicious plant-based protein
offered in three premium formulations
for distinct stages in your life that
have different nutritional needs whether
you're doing reps at the gym or you're
more into walking dogs rituals essential
protein is perfect for everyone i
personally make a protein shake twice a
day and they're 20 grams of pea plant
protein keeps me going strong all day
long and rituals protein powder is made
to satisfy your bones brains and muscles
to help maintain your body as you age so
why not shake up your ritual today and
to make trying something new less scary
ritual offers a 100
money-back guarantee if you're not in
love plus iced coffee hour listeners can
get 10 off your first three months by
visiting ritual.com ich to add your
essential protein today that's
ritual.com
ich to get 10 off your first three
months thank you so much ritual for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast
tell us about your team now because my
understanding is that now you have a few
people that you've hired yeah we've
hired people now you know can we can we
make the announcement about
you no no we can't make that yet well
now you have to jack is looking for his
own jack aren't you yeah yeah i've hired
out a few of my projects right now and
it's really nice because then it gives
me more time to focus on other things
and more free time that i can just enjoy
and spend working working you know doing
things oh yeah i found someone to take
care of a few things for example this
podcast right now is being edited by a
new person oh
yeah will the audience know the
difference no
because you know why uh how long have
you had this jack for
like editing the podcast
just in general uh
a month and a half a month and a half
nobody's noticed yeah no one said
anything yeah i mean i think there is
such a value to having uh employees that
that can really help you advance oh yeah
uh there there is a point where and it's
always this tipping point where
sometimes you get to too many employees
to where it feels like
you you added another employee but
they're doing let me let me rephrase
this think about it this way you add one
employee
the productivity from that one person
amazing it helps you out so much you add
another person you get maybe fifty
percent you had another person you get
like twenty percent it feels like
sometimes there's this diminishing truth
it's diminishing marginal utility
gosh see that's what i've been telling
jack jack and i have been going back and
forth over this we we agree on ninety
percent of stuff there's ten percent
that we don't agree on and you know i
want i have my way and jack said on his
way but one of the things is hiring out
people and every guest we have on the
podcast is like you guys should be
hiring that out and they hear about my
schedule oh you're working 12 hours a
day you should be hiring that out find
someone else to script your video i'm
like you don't get it but uh they always
say higher and i see jack's eyes just
light up he's like we should hire we
need more people and i'm telling jack no
no i just don't think we're at that
place where the diminishing marginal
utility is so so that it's not worth a
basic salary so not to not to uh boost
your ego here kevin but i say look at
kevin i get you're the only example that
i've that i've ever given jack i'm like
look what kevin's doing whatever kevin's
doing i want to do that stuff well he's
posting several times a day
and but look i believe
but look at the productivity right but
do you mean do you want to do that as
well
i can't put i can't post too so
i don't think it's a fair comparison
just based off of the types of videos i
guess more broadly the way to look at it
is uh
at no point
should you have too many employees to
where you start feeling resentful like
the productivity is going down i think
that's the ultimate test and i've gone
through this many times once with uh my
construction company once with the
campaign and and then more recently
where uh i'll hire folks
same thing again construction campaign
and more recently hire folks first
lots of productivity second lots of
productivity feels great love it then
you add two three more or whatever now
all of a sudden it's like oh no the the
the last edition has not been what you
expected potentially
and now all of a sudden and this is the
dangerous part is if one person becomes
less productive everybody else sees that
as oh well if they can get away with
being less productive let me be less
productive and then it hurts the whole
ship that's interesting and that's
dangerous and it's so dangerous
especially if you're trying to build a
company because imagine if you took if
you had a five-person team and two of
them were slackers and but now you 10x
this and you had a 50-person team that
means you have 20 people on payroll that
you're paying
that are actually hurting right the
other 30. that's really bad so uh it's
really difficult to let people go but
sometimes it has to be done for the sake
of
of growing properly i think and it's
been really hard because i've done that
uh in the construction company i've done
that in the campaign and uh they'll
always become a time we have to do that
again
i love
hiring but i've also been very
frustrated because there are so many
times i've looked and i'm like okay i'm
paying somebody for eight hours for
something i can do in 30 minutes
and that's when like when you're having
those comparisons that's when you know
you have the wrong person for the job
right so that that i think uh is and i'm
not expecting somebody to work the way i
do yeah but like like if something takes
me two hours it shouldn't take you
20.
uh and sometimes there's a training
element to that as well and some people
just don't care
and that's a danger about us being
public finance
folks is they see oh well that's how
much money you're making yes you know
you owe me and we see this a lot in
society is that people have this belief
that well you owe me a living wage well
you owe me uh you know my rent or you
owe me this well
my belief has always been you should
provide your value first
uh prove how good you are first and then
get paid if you're not getting paid for
then it's time to move on right but for
example
one one
i'll just go back into the past one
person and i'll stop talking about this
no no i find it interesting okay keep
talking
so i'll i'll make a hypothetical example
because i i don't want to reveal numbers
for their own privacy's sake but let's
say somebody and again fake numbers here
uh but similar scale let's say somebody
started working uh for twenty thousand
dollars and uh you're like oh my gosh
this person has this incredible
perspective they're they're early to
work they're the last to work uh glass
to leave work and they provide
perspective that's valuable and they
really care even though they might make
mistakes which is totally normal
mistakes are different from lack of
caring right
they put in the effort and they try to
get better every day that person has uh
in my world gone from making 20k to
making 60k to making 120k different
scale larger scale but that exists and
and that in my opinion is what every uh
that's the goal if you're going to hire
folks is you want to hire people where
you're like i
i value them so much i will gladly pay
them more uh and if you're ever feeling
bitter they gotta go
and that is probably my biggest weakness
is i don't let people go soon enough you
know somebody told me yesterday i went
to sushi with them he's he's
does wholesaling like product hole
sailing with china so he's in the depths
with this whole supply chain nightmare
he does like um
little gorbanza bags where they put uh i
don't know like christmas things in or
whatever anyway he sells
but think about it like he buys them for
five cents sells them for a quarter
right that's the goal so he'll buy
thousands of these anyway so
he's very experienced working with
employees and he's always said that
unfortunately
if somebody's not productive uh in your
company you've hired them what they're
really doing is there's no difference
between uh them being unproductive and
them just stealing from you at one point
and so he has this like really extreme
view of that and i think this is a
little too far but he's like if if
you're running a business and you want
it to be successful and you don't want
to go bankrupt like 50 to 60 percent of
businesses do go bankrupt
then you almost have to be and this is
such an evil word but he said it you
have to be a tyrant and uh to the point
where if somebody's not productive they
gotta go and you you always you wanna
give people warnings you want to be able
to train people right so there's there's
always that but beyond that if
somebody's
not caring and obviously their head's
not in the right place they don't care
about the success of the business they
got to go and so that's always been a
big struggle for me because i don't i
never want to be the guy that's like oh
you're fired like that is like
the worst possible thing like i just
want to be able to say i want a higher
higher higher but i know i'll go
bankrupt if i keep doing that how many
people do you have though right now uh
right now i have uh
let's see here
uh we just hired an in-house cpa
and that would bring us to five and i
should probably be at four tell me about
this in-house cpa that's
interesting how does this work well so
one of the frustrating things that i've
had is
bookkeeping is is very complicated when
you have multiple different businesses
going on it's one thing if you're
running your own like mint.com and you
have business and it's just a side
hustle or something of your personal
income and you have maybe what like two
or three transactions a day to look at
but if you have
multiple rental properties multiple
different businesses
multiple different employees multiple
different notices and insurances that
you have to deal with with the state and
and follow up on insurance policies to
make sure you're protected in all these
different ways whether it's
you know every business has liability
insurance there's an emissions insurance
then there are umbrella insurances and
that's for every business so we might
have 20 or 30 insurance policies and
it's just exhausting so we i can't do it
myself uh and i've had a lot of problems
trying to say okay well i'll outsource
and hire a bookkeeper because the
bookkeeper i'll give them sort of my
notes on what the expenses were a really
good trick that i think everybody can
use quick tangent is just use like with
lauren i use this little spreadsheet so
i have a little number spreadsheet on my
phone we're synced together every time i
spend some money let's say i spent seven
dollars on this i'll put seven dollars
personal expense
uh or uh 18
uh business purchase for amazon real
estate and then that way a bookkeeper
can later go in and and organize
and chart that all
but i've found that not having somebody
in person is like a nightmare because
i'll end up just getting an email from
an outsourced bookkeeper every three
months and they're like okay here's all
the things we have questions on and i'd
have to sit there for like 20 hours to
answer their questions and then at that
point it's like i may as well just do it
myself every day so now i wanted to
bring somebody in-house so we'll
probably pay them you know somewhere
around 120 180 000 somewhere that's
about the range for that wow
yeah that's tax deductible right and i
expect that's going to save me a lot
more in the event there was ever an
audit in the future yeah this would be
the best insurance policy for that
somebody who's like okay you spent money
on that give me the receipt i'm going to
document it i'm going to sort it
so if they're in-house are they how
often do you see them well i i really
like seeing employees every day
not that i don't want to micromanage
people because i i don't have the time
to micromanage people this is another
difficult thing like people have to be
self-motivated uh which i would love to
hire self-motivated uh computer
programmers or editors to come come work
but it's also hard to find people right
now but beyond that uh i like seeing
people every day because that way if we
sit down in a room in the morning middle
of the day afternoon like okay here are
the latest problems okay here are the
latest questions and and so that way
it's kind of like i post a video i can
go in sit down and create what do you
got what do you got what do you got and
we can sell things right away as opposed
to like i gotta get back to the email so
i gotta call this person back it's so
much easier in person that's interesting
that's what jack and i were talking
about uh gosh not even a few weeks ago
yeah it would save us because it's
already difficult enough to get paid
between graham and i because we have
different set percentages on all of our
different business ventures and then
there's 30 on some payments and at 45.
that's 75 on some payments oh yeah the
sponsors are a pain and to balance all
of that out is a total headache for
example i just recently got paid from
the month of july
that was like yeah i think that was like
like last week maybe yeah the week prior
but just because it's so much of a
headache to go through that entire
spreadsheet and not only that but also
like just bill collecting in general
when you have like tons of sponsorship
revenue coming in all the time or like
frequent checks you know coming in even
his rental properties stuff like that
like dividing up the payment between
alex graham and i on this the family the
iced coffee hour clips all this stuff it
would make sense to have someone just to
handle we're doing it all ourselves
basically but for the time saved but
first i want to thank our sponsor trent
jack have you heard about trends no i
haven't but man i sure wish i had some
sort of service that would tell me about
all these new things that are coming out
well i have great news man trends is
exactly what you're looking for business
and finance is an extremely competitive
space and it always feels like everyone
around me is one step ahead but that is
until i got trends trends is a
networking hub with a thriving community
of entrepreneurs and ambitious people
and they're constantly learning and
collaborating on business ideas and
projects trends even host live business
training and q a sessions where you can
learn the latest marketing tactics and
fundraising strategies from their team
of business analysts and when you
subscribe you instantly get access to
the trends community meaning you could
potentially link up with other ambitious
people kind of like yourself don't make
the same mistake others have made and
learn from the accumulated wisdom of
people just like yourself that have made
their dream a reality trends is a tool
to help you find a very valuable mentor
and guidance in the sometimes scary
world of work and being an entrepreneur
man if only i had trends to teach me
about trends months ago
so take advantage of this special offer
that they are only giving to iced coffee
our listeners when you visit trends dot
co slash ich you can get a seven day
trial for just one dollar that's trends
dot co slash ich to get a seven day
trial for just one dollar thank you so
much trends for sponsoring this episode
and back to the podcast
yeah and and see there are some really
cool uh things that i think a great cpa
can help you out on a lot as well see
there's something called a research
development tax credit i'll give you a
quick example of this there's a limit to
it i think the limits 250 000 a year but
i'll give you an example let's say you
spent uh 500 000 on on a new business
idea that was a new innovation or
something like that
well you so you can write that off so in
california i'd i'd
take a 500 000 write-off which would
save me about 250k in taxes so i spent
500k on a new idea that saves me 250k in
taxes which means i've taken 250 000 out
of my pocket and and spent it in reality
but now there's this research and
development tax credit where you can
take 30
as a tax credit on top of that so 30 of
500k is 150k credit
uh to offset that 250k so now i've
actually only taken 100 000 out of my
pocket to do 500 000 worth of work
that's really incredible that's
something to look into that's the
research development tax credit and
again it has to be for something
innovative there rules for it you could
only do it for five years 250k max per
year so what did you spend that on this
year well i haven't this year okay uh
but i i plan to in the next years yeah
yeah wow why didn't you do it for this
year you still got another week yeah
come up with an idea kevin right well
because i would want to maximize the
whole credit yeah see the like i don't
want to
start it this year and then only use
like 50k because then you're five years
one of those years has chopped off maybe
i do but see this is where it'd be nice
to have a cpa we're like oh no we do
already have 250k
but you know got it accounting is a
payment it's too bad you wouldn't be
able to buy a 500 000 asset be like
we're testing this out as research and
we're going to buy this picasso over
here right
that i'm gonna hang up in my living room
for business purposes and uh research it
and that's the other thing that makes me
so nervous now is that there are so many
creative things you can do but if if you
don't document it very well
you
and then you have you know like an
administration that we have now that
talks about okay let's ramp up audits
10x what we've been doing then you're
going to have a cancerous audit that's
going to live with you and you're just
going to hate your life trying to go
through that if you have somebody
in-house who does this full-time i mean
that's obviously a different level like
i don't recommend that for everybody
right but having good books is so it
gives you a lot of peace of mind yeah
tell us about the other four people you
have though
yeah uh well so what do they do uh well
we we do various different things uh the
biggest thing that i'm trying to train
folks to do and it's so difficult is
research this is probably the most
important thing is trying to find good
research
and there's plenty of research out there
it's just a matter of finding it so uh i
have subscriptions to whether it's vanda
track or bloomberg terminal or these
other services and they cost thousands
of dollars a month but to me they're the
cheapest employees because
you know bloomberg terminal i now get
access to let's say 2 000 researchers uh
that that are consolidating information
there i don't have to pay for all those
salaries right but now what we're trying
to do is find information so that could
be oh jpmorgan published an analyst
report and they see a trend happening in
i don't know electric batteries or
something like what batteries for
electric vehicles finding little pieces
like that and putting them into larger
bits of content is really useful and i
think it gives folks a reason to keep
coming back to the channel
and so that's what i really like doing
is finding unique perspectives or unique
content that i haven't thought of before
so just as an example
one of the things that
i thought of recently was
it seems like that in all the math kind
of reiterated this but just bottom line
it seems like the hedge funds are
shorting stocks purposefully where
retail investors are not investing
because they're scared about what
happened with amc and gamestop where
they what hedge funds are really doing
is i in the case of gamestop i think
they want a gamestop to go bankrupt but
most of the time hedge funds are trying
to
protect their overall accounts from
losing money so they pick some stocks to
hedge in the event the market crashes
they think they'll pick up money on on
that hedge uh so but now they're worried
about this whole
wall street bets retail movement coming
in and seeing oh the short interest is
high here let's all rush in and squeeze
these hedgies out and burn them when a
lot of hedge funds and i'm not trying to
defend hedge funds but there are
definitely some crooked ones but a lot
of hedge funds are really just trying to
make sure that if the market crashes
they don't lose everything and then
these older clients right
uh so
what i noticed is there are four
companies particularly lemonade shift
technology uh corsair and a tattoo chef
okay
these have all had substantial uh
declines in retail investments or even
outflows so there's a service i think
it's like three 3 500 bucks a month or
whatever and they'll tell you where
retail investors are investing or not so
they parse out okay here's retail here's
you know institutional
and
when you notice that like tattoo these
four companies have had either zero
retail inflows or net outflows
and the short interest is like 30 to 33
percent
it's a sign that hedge funds can take
safety in shorting these companies
because they're unlikely to get squeezed
out
now they can track that on a daily basis
and if all of a sudden you saw a retail
spike then they could see oh
we don't necessarily have to go monitor
every social media forum somebody in the
retail community is now pitching this
stock they see the spike they can get
out early so it's that kind of
information that i just love and so i
spend most of my day
behind a computer screen trying to
research stuff like that and you and you
hire four people to do that with you
yeah yeah but most of that right now is
me training because it's very like we
don't teach that in school right uh
the uh like for example if i give uh
okay
an example here i
found this really really good uh piece
on uh the new york times they did this
phenomenal expose on certain youtuber
chinese travel bloggers getting paid by
the chinese communist party
to make positive views
yeah and it's really incredible about
how uh
the new york times even said uh people
uh will
have access to parts of china that uh
the media won't have access to like
western media so
reuters associated press or whatever
they're not allowed in certain areas but
then these bloggers are and then they
get a catered experience go here you
know these people are going to walk by
or whatever say nice things it's funny
you mentioned that because all of a
sudden i don't know how but the youtube
algorithm sometimes recommends me just
like stuff out the blue and then i watch
it out of curiosity and now it's just
like keeps recommending uh north korea
believe it or not uh and there was a
tour guide who went through north korea
and it was like this is what it's
actually like i got like eight million
views in like a year
and it was a very similar thing he
acknowledged that it was a very catered
tour and and they made it seem like
everything is fantastic
um but then that led to another video to
another video to another video and then
i was watching this auto documentary of
the whole thing that went on with him
uh but yeah but it's crazy how they are
they can spin the narrative it's uh
propaganda coming to youtube yeah and uh
you know there's always they're always
those jaded people in the comments like
oh paid chill or whatever like
i mean we're not paid by
companies or corporations or whatever
unless we disclose a sponsor but it's
interesting to think that uh countries
would do that yeah uh and in that new
york times article they even mentioned
that uh
the communist party wanted the youtubers
to say things that were bad about the
communist party as well but to talk
about how great traveling was like oh
yeah they do this that's a little weird
but you know what they're they're
changing they're changing and kind of
like trying to acknowledge the
stereotype but then saying but don't
worry it's getting better and it's
really like this incredible psychology
then you look at the comments and all
the comments are like
can't wait to plan my next trip to
shanghai
no you know they planted those of course
yeah it's it's really like bots to the
top yeah
yeah it's it's very very interesting so
i thought that was incredible but anyway
so i was going to say about the so
employees in research right so all i
read that piece i you know i had a
coffee a couple nights ago i had a
coffee at like 11 p.m i'm like
jeez the reason for that is so i get the
i get six newspapers every day and i had
gotten like a week behind and when i get
a week behind on newspapers it's
this tall staff we're talking physical
newspaper physical these papers physical
nature okay and uh so i took the entire
stack and a cup of coffee and i went
through it and that was one of the
articles i found see i found the article
on like december 22nd but it was
actually published in the paper on uh
december like 16th had i not had the
physical paper i would have never seen
that story because the cool thing about
the physical paper is it's kind of like
blockchain we going through the
blockchain right it's this record that
doesn't change because it's there in
paper right whereas like the websites
are constantly updating a few hours a
few hours and so it's only the latest
stuff not the the stuff that could be
really interesting that's timeless so
anyway uh that's when i found that and
then i'm like okay hey let's go deep on
this and i asked somebody to like go to
some of these different videos and like
give me time stamps give me clips
because i myself went through some of
the videos and i'll say things you know
some people say i'm i'm bought by the by
the chinese government after this
article came out but but i'm not and
yeah i read off a teleprompter but i
swear i'm not getting a script from the
government and like in the new york
times article or like these people are
often getting scripts
but could there actually be a chance
though that they're being honest yes of
course of course uh and i think there's
it's a mix of both so i do think uh
there is
uh probably like hey say some nice
things about us we'll show you some
exclusive areas we'll take you to some
exclusive restaurants we'll pay that for
you and sometimes they'll acknowledge
that they'll say like hey you know i'm
getting this paid for
so i i don't necessarily blame the
creators so much maybe there should be a
little bit more transparency especially
with the comment section but the comment
section is sometimes a cesspool anyway
uh but it is i think the more
broadly interesting thing is
uh country propaganda now coming to
youtube yeah uh and then the reason i
brought this up as well is uh when when
uh working with and this is where i'm
trying to train uh employees because you
had asked about that initially
this is where it becomes very very
difficult because my thinking is okay i
want to be able to stitch together like
a 20-minute video putting together clips
comparing it to the article comparing it
to comments clips clips clips and then
this a deep dive which would probably
take me three hours to put together well
one person had worked on it for three
days
and i have no more than the summary of
the article and i'm like i had the
summary of the article
that night i gave you the summary of
that
and so i've talked to them about that
like hey let's let's go through let's do
this this this but that's where
sometimes i feel like i'm a bad boss
because it's like
i need to either train harder or there's
a lack of motivation or uh i'm just not
being really clear with my expectations
i don't know but that is one thing that
says frustrating stress made frustrate
me about being an employer no at that
point definitely i feel like three days
it's just lack of care and wouldn't they
have kept you updated throughout that as
well hey kevin this is taking a lot
longer than i thought it would some
people do and stuff like a lot of people
are afraid to ask though or they're
afraid to bring that up because they
don't want to acknowledge that i'm
having a difficult time these days to
come up with nothing virtually
it's it's painful because
then uh the thought is okay well maybe
are they just misplaced is there
something else that they could do uh is
there something else they could do
better uh but that's always so hard
because sometimes you wonder is it or
are they in the right place at all uh
are they um do they not like me anymore
are they resentful of me like what what
happened you know so it was interesting
i was talking to uh i was with jason
oppenheim last night and we got together
after a long time i haven't seen him for
a
while
he mentioned to me that that whatever
you get in like the first month usually
that's what you're going to get
the people don't change
um so he acknowledged that the people
who are really pushing themselves
they'll do that from the very beginning
there's there's nothing that you could
do to incentivize someone to push
themselves beyond what they're already
doing
um so
i i believe that and he's hired quite a
few people and and he's not been shy
about letting people go that just don't
fit very quickly yeah he's a smart and
shrewd business person yeah i admire
that about him and and so it's sad
because you know again you don't want to
be the person that fires people but yeah
but i did want to talk about something
else uh there's a lot of i notice a lot
of people they give like
real estate or mortgage advice on tick
tock and i'm just shaking my head and
i'm like okay well i i maybe i need to
go in there and make some and i'm not
trying to say like my perspective is
right i just have a very particular
perspective like no that's not the kevin
way and again you know what it sucks
because everyone is and i acknowledge
tick tock is something that we should
all be doing yeah all of us know we
should it's like going to the gym like
you know you should be going to the gym
every day but you don't do it yeah and
tick tock is one of those things for me
where it's just i can't i can't seem to
get into it and it's so i don't like how
basic it is like i see the people doing
well sure and uh mark tilbury is a
perfect example of someone who's done
tik tok incredibly well he's done
everything right for tick tock but it's
so
basic
and i like that's how i started on
youtube is doing those really basic
videos like the three best index funds
to buy like what an index fund is
i can't bring myself to do that again
but he's doing it and it's doing so well
i think it's because you're trying to
mentally grow and you've so checked out
of the basics uh i i
empathize with this uh that it's kind of
like ah do i really want to explain
whether you should pay down your 30-year
fixed-rate mortgage at three percent or
not you know do you want to pay that
offer do i really want to go through
that again uh and and i get it like i'd
rather be like oh my gosh like what is
the latest barclays research and maybe
the latest cutting edge thing that's
going on or whatever uh that makes me
excited and i feel really successful
doing that but that stuff doesn't do
well on tick tock no
but you have to realize dude
for myself is that like this is a new
audience like you're saying this to new
people who have never seen you before
and have no idea what they're doing
honestly even if you posted those
original videos again or just remade
them on your main channel there'd
probably be a lot of people who are part
of your new audience that have yeah well
that's what i do every now and then as i
take the old videos that have done well
from like two to three years ago and i'm
like how could i just update this and
make sure better
and uh there's definitely i would say
the the maybe the few percent of people
who notice that graham you made this
video three years ago but nobody goes
don't watch it nobody goes back and
watch the old videos yeah yeah but but i
mean those people are like i've seen
this before it's like okay and click out
and wait for the next one yeah no i i
agree with you you know the most fun
i've had on a video recently was the
metaverse video and that was that was
your idea jack and what was it at 10
what was it oh
tied with the one it was like a few
thousand views away from the one but the
one just kept doing better but uh yeah
it was a new topic that i just immersed
myself in for 48 hours i spent a long
time on that video doing everything i
could i loved it that's funny so much
fun yeah and that's no see because now
you walk away from that with all this
extra knowledge too about the metaverse
yeah that's what's interesting i've been
trying to re uh reinforce and graham is
that he needs to do new stuff because
that's what you're great at you're
constantly reading stuff and keeping
people up to date on like all these new
things that are happening but a lot of
the times like we're still posting
videos like credit cards like how to
increase your credit score and i know
that those do well but at the same time
if you push the envelope a little bit
like andre's doing as well with like the
metaverse stuff and he even did an
options video which you've never wanted
to explore yeah pushing the envelope a
little bit and trying out new things i
think is the only way that you can just
not die out as a youtube channel all
right because people don't want to see
the same thing over and over again but
do you worry about that i have a feeling
you feel the same way about like every
day is the same for the market opens
market closes
do you feel like every day is like oh
you know
we're doing neo again
neo's up to 33 tesla's down yeah i mean
to some degree uh you had actually
mentioned that you like watching i love
coming yeah maybe maybe i think the
question is for you we gotta ask you
graham because yeah i mean something
like i wake up and i'm like oh i gotta
you know it's early yeah the market open
market close and sometimes i'll be in
the middle of research in the middle of
the day like i've got to go do that
market close right so it feels like a
little bit of a wedge in the day uh i
enjoy doing it doing it and obviously
people like it but i don't know graham
why do you like it you know what so i'll
be honest i've seen every single one of
your live streams for the last few
months uh well actually really since the
beginning i watched them all to speed uh
beginning to end every single one i
don't think i've missed a live stream
from you and in the morning it's it's
because it's become a part of my morning
routine where i don't start the day
until i turn on your live stream and i
have my coffee and i'm like you know
doing my own research while listening to
yours same with the the market end
uh the part i don't like sometimes is i
feel like sometimes the the stock is a
little repetitive when you're going
through every stock individually and
like this one's up this one's down this
is up i love the news when you go
through the news what's on the bloomberg
terminal let's do this i like you know
the stocks are good but i think the news
is interesting and i wonder if if you
took
15 minutes before and and before doing a
live stream yes to plan out the top five
news articles that you want to cover and
talk about just even if you glance over
it just a headline in a few sentences
it's a two-minute summary on this one
two minutes yeah
i think that's what would make a
difference because i love the news
yeah i like that i like the news portion
of that the best
what about um
tax write-offs have you thought about
tax reform this year yes yeah i oh i
didn't tell you guys neither one of you
guys
uh so i was talking to brandon turner
who introduced me to this guy who he
says is like the number one commercial
wholesaler
and i was blown away at this guy he's
like 30 years old we could get him on
the podcast if you guys want to see him
on the podcast just let us know he's 30
years old he's already got 100 million
dollars at the real estate
and himself or himself under management
himself
himself started from nothing as a as a
wholesaler but he's that good
and uh his thing is basically he'll
he'll find like a vacant building and
he'll do all the work to basically say
if you buy this building we could get
this tenant and in there and the
tenant's going to start they're going to
sign a 10-year like big tenants they're
going to have a 10-year lease he just
has the connections he's so
knowledgeable but i explained the
situation to him and i said
you know i got like two weeks uh and i
got this big tax bill coming up and i
would love to spend enough on a property
to write off that tax bill and he came
to me with a deal it didn't work out
because i he couldn't guarantee that it
closed by the end of the year and it was
a lot of work but it was like 80 units
in in minneapolis
and it was a fixer-upper so he's like
and it was 22 million dollars and he
said the seller the seller was willing
to carry some of the loan
um
i love this deal honestly it's just i
couldn't guarantee to close and it would
be a lot of work so he says you're gonna
be spending probably the next six to
eight months fixing it up and i'm like i
can't
do that but uh
basically i take all my cash that i have
sitting on the sidelines for taxes and i
put it into this building instead
segregated cost aggregated the first
year write-off was almost six million
dollars in the first it has to be in
service for you to get the write-off so
you would have had to i guess call it
in-service with the existing tenants and
then renovate it okay i guess you could
do that yeah well that's one of the cool
things about
being in the real estate industry is you
could take that that loss against some
of your other ordinary correct but i
don't that's not necessarily open to
everybody but uh unless you're like a
broker
right so the downside though couldn't
guarantee to close by the end of the
year so that wouldn't work so it didn't
from that standpoint but also it was
more work than i wanted to take on and
for such a big purchase like that's a
purchase that i would probably spend a
month or two like really analyzing and
to and he's like if you need this deal
you have to get everything into the
lender by 6 p.m today
and i was like i have until 6 p.m
they've already done appraisers they've
done everything on it but uh yeah i
would be curious to know i think this
would be an interesting podcast guess
because how so what did they start with
uh and and i am skeptical that they have
a 100 million portfolio of themselves
maybe they do they could do that with
you know
i mean maybe it was 20 million dollars
of equity that uh it was a really good
deal and then financed that they were
able to balloon into a 100 million
dollar portfolio yeah i'm sure there's
there's obviously going to be debt uh
still i mean even if there's 65 million
dollars it doesn't matter uh or even 50
million that's still a lot yeah that's
created by 30. so it'd be really
interesting to see how that built up
right so i think that would be
phenomenal the other option is so this
year i basically i'm going to pay a big
tax bill it just it is what it is i you
know i waited too long so that was my
fault on that but uh the other option i
was thinking about maybe doing something
with brandon brandon turner from bigger
pockets and maybe we could work together
on a deal and i could go on 50 50 with
him or so something like that
like mobile homes correct he has a
syndicate where he's correct basically
buying parks yeah okay okay but it was
interesting to hear him talking about
mobile homes and how he runs that
business and it's it's the cash flow
from these mobile homes is incredible to
make 12 to 15
uh to have very little responsibility
other than management like you're not
fixing up these mobile homes yourself
they owned them you're running the land
correct
very interesting and then sometimes you
could buy the mobile homes and then sell
them and then you're
carrying basically this this mobile home
that you own but what kind of how could
you cost segregate because you can't
appreciate land so how do you get a tax
right off doing that
buying the mobile homes and then selling
the actual yeah right and then selling
them to the people who live there i see
and so instead of taking out a mortgage
on a house you are basically you are the
lender for the asset that you own oh i
see okay you guys are lending on them
correct that's what he's doing as well
that's incredible because then you're
almost it's almost like you're buying
inventory yeah
because they're
like registered with a dmv right
so that's that's very interesting there
are so many creative things you can do
sometimes i worry that uh that end of
the year rushed for tax write-offs leads
to bad decisions which i almost made
what was your bad decision i wanted to
buy a plane
um
the grant cardone clip right here this
is a clip the grant cardone method well
uh it's mostly because i i also you
could put kp on the side of the plane
it's just me lying down and then right
capital right where the landing gear
comes out it's like right you know
uh but
what's interesting about it is so
picture this i'm just going to use round
numbers here to make an example let's
say you had a 20 million dollars of
income and you bought a 20 million
dollar plane you put 10 percent down on
it that means you're putting two million
dollars down
and then you're saving about ten million
dollars in taxes yeah uh that tax
write-off would pay probably for
operating a plane for three to maybe
three and a half years pilots hangar
fees landing fees gas maintenance
they're expensive it's crazy
uh the problem with this
is uh well multifolded uh one you have
to have a really good use for the plane
the puerto rico idea would have made a
lot of sense that we talked about
earlier now that would make a lot of
sense to have your own playing for
uh the
second problem though is if you ever had
to resell it
you'd have you'd be hit with all the
depreciation recount recapture so let's
say you know is that taxed as ord that's
ordinary income then do we capture
absolutely yeah yeah it's not a capital
investment yeah just be ordinary income
so
uh that would be really bad
because then let's say in three years
you're like i'm gonna sell this plan you
sell it for 15 million or whatever all
of that 15 would be taxed so you're
paying seven and a half or whatever in
taxes
uh which would hurt uh but then the
probably the biggest thing that really
hurt everything for for all of the math
that i was doing beside purposes for it
is uh the amount of inflation you have
right now
and
in in plain values so people are selling
planes today for
uh 25 million dollars that they bought
for 22 million no
why 23 years ago because if well first
of all because it is such a lucrative
tax advantage people are like i don't
care i want it right like i want the tax
write-off but the airplane manufacturers
are so
behind because they can't get chips or
parts out of china or whatever they're
dealing with labor shortages like
there's this uh airline manufacturer or
airplane manufacturer called embraer uh
if i wanted to buy a phenom 300 which is
like an 8 million list price plane uh
and and it could get me around
california probably to texas i don't
think i could get to florida without
stopping but i could get to texas so
it'd be a really good like middle of the
united states and west coast like if you
were gonna do a real estate fund or
something you could get around easily
and then you know i got an airport 10
minutes away in oxnard which is really
cool and convenient but anyway uh if i
wanted to buy one new i would have to
wait until the summer of 2023 to get one
and if i bought a used one i'll be
overpaying so now imagine this worst
case scenario you take the tax write-off
by a plane after three years you realize
you don't need it
now not only did you overpay so your
depreciation is is like massive like
your loss on actually having that asset
is massive but then you're paying
depreciation recapture the extra taxes
you'd get screwed
uh so and it's just like do you really
need it is probably a bigger question uh
as opposed to just that's really
interesting it makes sense because used
cars right now are insane
so what's cool the ford gt i bought i
paid 306 for it
one just sold with the almost identical
mileage on it for 390. and that was that
was only eight months what maybe eight
eight or nine months later so that car
did just as well as the s p 500
yeah it i don't think it'll last i'm not
trying i don't think so no no i'm not
trying to slam your car no no that's
also a concern that i have about buying
something like if you bought a plane
let's say and you overpaid for it
well then you're literally buying at the
top of the market first
here's my thought let's say the market
does end up going down or it softens for
cars like that my thought is that the
people buying those planes or buying
those cars or in a position where they
don't need to sell it yes at a loss yes
so like for me for example let's say i
did pay the 390 for this car and now
it's worth 330. yes i just be ah you
know what you know unless i need to sell
it i'm not gonna sell it i'm just gonna
hold it so it's a bit of a different
mark like the art market's very similar
but see uh the huddle costs for art are
like zero minus maybe some insurance the
model costs for your car i mean what is
it gonna cost you maintain your car in
your garage probably i don't know two
grand a year max yeah it's not much yeah
but the
costs for a 20 million dollar plane are
probably one and a half to two million
dollars a year yeah that's true hanger
fees there's limited hanger space
because everybody wants a plane now how
much does a hanger cost
uh
you know i i have kind of just lumped it
all together that my my uh fixed costs
for a 20 million dollar plane yeah are
are about one and a half to two that's
good
my understanding is part of the variable
the hanger fees could be like five to
six thousand or i guess three to seven
thousand a month depending on the size
of the plan right yeah i mean the way
just
i mean quick quick math it was probably
something to the effect of a hundred
grand a month as your payment on the
plane right yeah uh you're probably
looking at
uh somewhere around a depreciation of um
one and a half uh a year
on some of these in depreciation right
just lost value that's not even a cost
that's just you know your asset value is
losing one and a half a year because if
that plane is 10 years old it's gonna be
worth half as much it is now it's not an
appreciating asset like real estate
uh then you have uh
yeah uh the maintenance stuff breaks
yeah uh and so you don't want stuff to
break when you're in the sky so you're
paying uh massive uh warranty programs
uh massive fees for warranty programs so
that way your engines hopefully don't
break and and little sensors don't break
they were showing me because i visited
some of the planes uh they were showing
me that one of these little needle
sensors that looked about this long
maybe uh just a little needle that came
out of the front of the plane
measures uh altitude and all these
altimeter i don't know i don't know
playing stuff measures a bunch of stuff
they said if that somebody just like
walked into it and like bent it a little
bit and we had to replace it it'd be
seventy five thousand dollars oh yikes
this little tiny thing you wanna paint
the plane because you can't wrap a plane
you have to paint a plane why can't you
wrap it well because it decided to keep
it painted so well i mean if you don't
uh but i mean i just i wanted to paint
myself on it because that's what i do
crazy
but uh you you can't wrap it because you
put your phone number on the side of
this absolutely man uh everything that
you do uh in aerospace has to be
approved by the uh faa and anything that
increases the drag on the outside no no
because now you've changed all of the
calculations for the plane
you want to paint the outside of the
plane this plane we're looking at three
hundred thousand dollars no
way you want listen to this so interior
you have like
lumber
for the the
next to the upholstery you know where
your armrests are and whatever and you
wanted that to look good uh you
you could restain it all for 280 000
just for restaining the lumber inside of
the plane uh which is so different is
that due to like regulations or is that
dude
because i feel like you could just pay a
handy day yeah right
stain it right so any change to a plane
has to again be certified so
certifications oh the ins inside
everything you cannot
really you can't change anything on the
inside let's see
are they gonna are they gonna know do
people do is it like a rental property
where it's like yeah you're supposed to
put the ac in with a permit but people
do it without it i mean here's the thing
uh i was actually thinking about wanting
to do like
the mile high podcast
and do like a podcast on it it's a great
name for the podcast yeah now somebody's
gonna take it
um but so i was thinking about that uh
but the problem is if you're
flying it's noisy you could use good
microphones that's useful but where are
you going to fly you're just going to
fly in circles and waste a bunch of gas
like that's that's very bad people are
getting used as a set though right so
but then you use it as a set
have you ever been on a plane when it's
on the ground and you're like please get
in the air because it's so hot
you ever get that feeling no you don't
wouldn't you have like recirculating
errands so let me see i'll okay you
could build a set that just looks like
my question to you all didn't work but
every time i get on a plane i'm like
please turn the freaking air on and it
isn't until you're actually getting
airborne that you're getting really good
circulation uh maybe people in the
comments can justify me up here but um
so i asked them to close all of the
little things and we closed them up and
we cranked the ac there because you know
you know my studio it's ice cold in
there they crank the ac and i'm like
it's hot you're sitting on the tarmac
black you know that heat is reflecting
up
it sucked uh it was not a good set like
you said it would be better to just
build a fake set yeah that looks like
you're inside of a plane than actually
film inside a plane i wanted to mount
cameras and lights and i'm like oh well
i could just use like clamps or whatever
nope no no you change anything to the
weight dynamics or whatever it's a
cluster f i think
uh if you're looking for a good
write-off this year do the plain idea i
like i hate it i i feel like i'm giving
kevin like a way to compete with us now
cause kevin's gonna do well doing the
mile high podcast hey man i'm an
abundance mentality type of guy really
i'm more of a keep it to ourselves
if you did
uh like you had the plane here and you
had like the really nice seats and you
had uh like uh lcd or led screens
as the the windows and you could project
like lightning and stuff like that like
how cool would that be
or you could project like you know
clouds like kind of like passing by or
whatnot
as though you're in an airplane yeah and
you could even like if you want to go
crazy you could do it
as though like you rotate the uh the
cameras a little bit to make it seem
like you're taking that would be cool
and you could act it all right we're
going to take off now with our guests
and you rotate the cameras a little bit
make it seem like you're going back or
you put the whole thing on a hydraulic
you know so like some of the sticks are
actually it's getting some turbulence
sometimes but it's just the camera
shaking that would be funny or no you
actually have it as though like the
whole set kind of like moves up and down
to your drinks kind of shake and whatnot
so
so i went uh so i did a podcast with uh
codyko's people recently and check out
their set so they did that yeah i did
that
uh yeah it wasn't it wasn't with kodiko
it was their trillionaire
mindset the trillionaire mindset or
something oh so that yeah but anyway
that's their set and they have it so
that these are
screens the giant tvs basically they
have mounted here that make it seem like
you're in space
the whole thing and so like constantly
everything seems like you're just in
space
yeah it's so
one of the things that i've noticed is
uh i honestly don't know how much people
care about the set people come for the
value uh of the content now that's a
thesis that i have i could see that
matters okay that's your opinion
no that's a nope that's a that's a fact
and i'll
i saw i saw your video about an argument
you want me to make an argument
so
i've done both without a set with a set
my videos have done substantially better
with a set the iced coffee hour i
noticed an almost immediate difference
when we did the set i told jack i didn't
think the set mattered at all i liked
the couch approach because i thought oh
you know it's it's more casual it's more
natural having a real conversation
and uh you know i didn't think it was
needed we did the set almost immediately
the videos started doing better i think
it adds a sense of uh professionalism
and when people are even even when
you're accounting for any better
retention like do you think your videos
would be a five percent better retention
even one percent better retention with a
nice set
well uh
so i i agree with you i think like
having a beautiful set has has its
benefits uh uh and who knows maybe
they'll encourage people to come back
more but
personally i think the most important
thing in in our space compared to like a
vloggers kind of podcast or an
entertainer's kind of podcast i think uh
in our space we're always trying to
provide value to people like hey here's
a new way for you to make money here's a
new way to think about something here's
a way to succeed or whatever i think if
if that's missing i don't care what set
you got nobody's watching your crap
whereas you could be in front of a wall
if you're providing the best information
possible people love you look just as an
example look at the guy uh dr john
campbell maybe maybe put like a little
b-roll of his setup or whatever it's
just him in front of his his uh
laptop webcam and then he has a paper
camera where he shows like some of his
statistics on a piece of paper and he
moves it around you see his finger on it
or whatever
nobody cares at all about a set the
guy's got like
over the last month because of omicron
he got a hundred million views in a
month nobody cares at all what do they
care about this guy knows what he's
talking about he's knowledgeable he's
researched i want the fact that can you
sustain that and that's the thing yeah i
don't think because we actually saw the
views on his channel ramp during the
initial covet search but then plummet
substantially when covet wasn't a big
topic anymore so you're right so that's
where maybe does maybe the set help with
sustainability and what do you think i
think it matters but there's extreme
diminishing marginal utility as we
discussed prior oh yeah i agree with
that with set so it's like as long as
you have a good set you're fine but like
realistically you could drop like easily
200 300 000 on like a super nice set but
like it's not gonna have i don't think
it could necessarily bring that much
value back to you if you already have a
five to ten thousand dollar set for
example the iced coffee are a set all in
with cameras and everything is about
twelve thirteen thousand dollars no way
no these three cameras are worth more
than that
right
okay well we got the custom table for
free so if we throw that in yeah maybe
it'd be like closer to twenty thousand
dollars but still at the same point it's
like we could have a two three like i
mean yeah if we you know shield at the
cash or whatever but i don't know if it
would necessarily bring us back that
much value in the next like three years
yeah that's also true just because it's
good enough but that's the couch was not
good enough that was really nice i mean
i okay i think that's a fair middle
ground it's like hey we've got uh good
enough set good enough cameras like i've
always asked like oh should i make a new
set would it bring remember we went to
disney or what was it disney or
hollywood whatever
disneyland the harry potter was it you
saw the bookshelf in the harry potter uh
universal right yeah whichever way we
went on the harry potter room
and uh wherever the harry potter ride is
we went on that and there was this
really sick library set up i loved it
where it looked like a sorcerer's table
and all these books and it was it was a
gorgeous set yeah i mean that set design
is probably worth half a mil right there
is so good
would people watch my videos more
because of that set
in a way i do think uh the answer could
be yes but then
and this is the hard question is would
it bring us that money back and see this
is the question that i had to make or
ask myself with plain as well is like if
i'm spending three million dollars a
year on on a plane after my tax
write-off period pays for itself so
first three years free basically because
of the tax write-off and then i pay
three million dollars a year for a plan
am i going to make three million dollars
more per year because i have this and if
the answer is sure you'll make three
million dollars more per year is it
worth breaking even like it i have to
have a return on it to do it right
uh and i think sometimes we get lost and
this happened to me like i admit i
almost screwed up like i got so caught
up in i should do it i should take the
tax right off but then i haven't really
proven the need for it yet or the return
on that and it's the opposite of what i
do in real estate like would i buy a
house because i'm like oh i i really
love this house it's my tenants are
gonna love this or am i gonna buy uh
rental property because the numbers make
sense either it cash flows really well
or it's an upside down deal like a wedge
deal right yeah like i do that for real
estate why would i not do that with with
a plane so that's when i finally
realized something all right
i would argue realistically if you're
gonna drop three hundred thousand
dollars on a new set you would get a way
better roi paying someone even if it's a
hundred grand to just post stuff on tick
tock if you're looking at our probably
yeah you're probably right
you would get way much more value doing
that than
you know what a daily news segment would
actually be really and you could do this
so easily just daily news segment 45
seconds or you just summarize 10 seconds
of topic yes exactly that would do
really well i would try that kevin for
30 days
and you don't even have to post seven
days a week five days a week at and you
have to stay consistent it's like 4 p.m
a day monday through friday
45 seconds 45 seconds here's what's
happened in the market today and i have
a feeling in the beginning you're not
going to do much because people are
going to be scrolling tick tock and be
like ah you know i'm not interested i
think after 30 days of you doing that
you're going to gain such a loyal
audience who's going to look forward to
that
that's a very good idea yeah yeah i
wrote it down and that's i like that's
the trick with tick-tock it just has to
do that quick when i say i might do that
i should tell myself
and the good thing with that with you is
that i know you could do it in one take
and i think your total i honestly i
think your total time commitment per day
on that because you've already done the
research anyway is probably five minutes
a day realistically so very good idea
yeah i i mean i encourage people like
you know this is a big question i think
we always get all the time too if like
hey i want to be a creator too like what
should i do post just freaking post and
and this is what i'm literally not doing
on take talk because i'm just not
posting and i'll be like oh but i don't
know what to wake i don't know what to
make well make try it try 10 different
things on take talk try 10 different
things on youtube and guess what after a
month you're gonna look back and go
well that did well that failed okay do
more what does well that could do well
but i'll only know if i try it you know
what speaking of which i called it first
if we could do a tick tock at the end of
this
oh okay with you yeah absolutely all
right i'm happy i'm happy i called it
first i said it versus my dear jen
my idea i look i i think it's the
collaboration that's it's so awesome um
what about um so for next year what are
you gonna do tax-wise you're gonna go
buy a property real estate i'm i'm like
95
set on buying a property because i i got
uh how much i get i got seven million
invested in stocks this year okay
congratulations i basically yeah so i i
wanted my stocks in real estate to
almost be 50 50 and when i count equity
in the real estate versus equity in the
stocks it's almost 50 50. actually it
would be 50 50 you count uh like
cryptocurrency and stuff like that
so i would count that so yeah so i hit
my goal this year to be 50 50 between
stocks and real estate on that so now i
think i want to get back to real estate
but just because i think the tax credits
are so great and i'm realizing too like
i got in the stocks thinking oh you know
if i spent three percent a year then
that could be you know whatever's three
percent of seven million you know 210 a
year i could live off of and passive
income forever and then i'm thinking to
myself well
realistic i'm never going to sell like i
look at the dividends and that that
portfolio generates i think it's 58 000
a year in dividends wow and i think to
myself well i'm just going to live off
of 58. why live off the 210. so i think
psychologically i can't sell something
even if i were to retire i couldn't sell
the three percent of the year i love it
so i think for real estate
i think it makes sense because then at
least i'd have some cash flow that is
coming anyway
and uh it forces you to yeah you'll you
know be uh i don't know what like 95 how
old would you do that in 30 years
i'd carry the two
but
but you know then these properties are
paid off too i mean not necessarily i
mean when you're retired that's great
imagine i mean i was talking to somebody
like i mentioned that wholesaler
yesterday
so he's got uh i don't know 20
properties or something like that and uh
i think he's
about 80 paid off
relatively close to retirement and uh
probably somewhere in the neighborhood
of um
you know i guess without disclosing too
much um
multi hundreds of thousands of dollars
in just passive income doesn't have to
do anything every year but the
interesting
challenge or issue that he has is he's
like
kevin i want to do something and so it's
such a weird thing to see that in him
who's you know in his i don't know how
old he is 60 65 or something like that
uh you know we we think oh we're going
to retire when we're 65. i couldn't
retire i don't think i could retire now
either you know he and he's in that
place where it's like i don't have to do
anything
the properties just pay for it you know
you buy them and over time you pay them
off now they're paid off now what i was
like what's the next thing he keeps
asking me kevin what am i going to do
when i grow up
and it's like it's really interesting
it's
there's something just about working i
don't know i can't retire either people
the same way what's the the most common
question i get kevin what's what's the
number where you're just like that's it
sell everything and retire you know it's
like it's not about a number the whole
game for me is not about a number yeah
graham you have a number
i did no at first i looked through my
old reddit posts by the way from like uh
notice five oh wow it was five and this
is when i was probably 22 or 23
and i remember posting on the financial
independence subreddit i'm like you know
five million would be my number that
would be enough to get like a nice like
one and a half million dollar place in
los angeles you could invest the rest in
rental property and that would be enough
um but yeah and then it was 10. uh
now it's going to be i mean i don't have
a number but you know milestones 20 i
think would be just the next milestone
just a hit but i think a hundred a
hundred to me seems like yeah a tenth of
a bill a tenth of a billion yeah that's
that's big but i just want i just want
to see the hundreds
no okay so
but it wouldn't change anything yeah no
it doesn't change no that's the thing is
if anything it just gives you an
opportunity to to start businesses or to
do things that you couldn't have
otherwise done what do you think about
the whole like the elon musk like tax to
rich thing and stuff like that i don't
know if you want to talk about that if
that's not we can talk about what about
it specifically well just
you know there uh there's there's all of
this talk about okay we should raise
taxes on on people who have over a
certain net worth or tax people based on
their net worth oh they're off this yeah
the wealth effect does that
disincentivize people from from doing
projects or working yeah i gotta say if
the ta if well
yes and no because if if the tax rate
were high enough for me i'd spend it so
if let's say the tax rate was 90 percent
if i didn't spend it you guaranteed i'd
be spending all of it that's true what
would be the point yeah so there's got
to be a middle ground between uh
where the tax rates make sense to
encourage spending but not enough to
disincentivize saving and i remember a
while ago i was doing research on like
the capital gains tax and it was 28 was
found statistically to be the point
where it would it would encourage you to
hold on long term but not enough to
incentivize you to sell so it was 28
i'm sure that also exists with taxes
to me i think 37 percent incentivizes
saving
with the mindset that most likely it's
going to be going up so i'd rather save
at 37
and spend later when it's 50 let's just
say and it's and it's worth more or
you're in california already at 50
percent or 52. i think it's 52 percent
or it's it's actually it's 50 what was
it 57 58 if you count short-term capital
gains with the net investment tax yeah
that's true because and then you're also
losing other benefits uh
yeah that's good so it was almost it was
or no it wasn't it
60 oh it would it would it would have
been 62 percent had they raised it back
up to 39 point yeah it was it was insane
but at 62 i'd be spending it um and i
would just i buy whatever just because
i'm like you know i may as well maybe
the argument there is would that
generate jobs or and that's the thing
too potentially so i think a higher tax
rate would encourage more spending that
would benefit the economy but
what is the cost of not saving or what
is the cost of um not reinvesting long
term
now what uh what about the
another concern i had with like the
plane idea is like oh my gosh but like
what if next year you get cancelled
right and now you have a plane yeah and
that liability does that ever cross your
mind
all the time because it could all just
go away you don't realize how fast
things could change
and uh you know i don't want to go into
examples but i've had probably three
times throughout the last few years that
i could think of where i thought this is
it
um and it's just and but it's insane how
quickly things could change like people
will love you one day and one comment or
one thing comes up and it's tide turns
and uh and there's very much a ripple
effect where it's like you say the wrong
thing
and then people
have to disassociate themselves because
then it reflects on them and in a way
it's like i get it if if let's say
you know i'm not accusing you of it but
let's just say something comes out with
you
and you know kevin's made out to be the
bad guy
we would almost have to disassociate
ourselves because if we work together
then it's like well you're supporting
someone who did this or said this even
if you're uh not guilty of it even if
it's just an accusation i disagree with
it does that matter if the public
perception says otherwise if everyone
believes something to be true even if
it's not
do i want to insert myself there and say
well
and that becomes the balance it's like
what's worth fighting for what's not
and yeah i uh i had this uh
really good in my opinion video that i i
spent days on making it was everything
about my campaign platform and i've had
b-roll in it about what's wrong with
california's water situation or homeless
situation or whatever
the video was about 45 minutes long and
i think it was
one of my best in terms of the problems
and solutions for california
but one little part of it
made a reference uh it had b-roll of the
homeless issue in california and ben
shapiro talking about how bad the
homeless problem is in california he was
right about everything he said about the
homeless problem and the b-roll was
perfect
that one clip
made a lot of folks think that uh oh
kevin support supports ben shapiro we
can't vote for him because we don't like
ben shapiro yeah and it's like
like you gotta be kidding me like what
he said was about homelessness and he
was worried about what he said don't you
agree don't care i hate ben therefore i
hate you
yeah it's it's scary honestly and uh you
know i've talked to jack about this too
it's just like it's all and it's always
the things that you're very careful like
i am so careful even what
i'll be on like even something having a
drink this is this is one of the few
times i've ever been on camera drinking
anything i don't swear i don't drink i
don't do anything i'm so i script
everything i say so it's you know i'm
really careful about what i say what i
want to put out there and i'm thinking
can someone misinterpret this and as
careful as you could be sometimes the
thing you'd never even think would be an
issue is an issue and it's like well i
didn't mean it that way
that wasn't my intention but i could see
how someone could perceive it that way
and it just it is what it is so i've
basically taken the approach that like
every
month i'm just month by month at this
point it's like every month you could be
perfect and thankful for what you have
okay yeah so like mentally and preparing
myself for like and i hate to like ever
will something into existence but i
never want to think of something like oh
i screwed this up but uh you know i i
just always think to myself i i'm really
grateful for where i've gone so far i've
gone way further than i ever would have
expected if something were to happen i'd
be really happy with with the point up
until you've done that's good right it's
like you're reaching like checkpoints in
a game and you're saving your progress
and like i didn't realize at that point
that's why i've saved everything you die
here it's fine
but that's why i've saved everything
it's because i know um you know one
thing or you know guilty or not one
thing could completely everything could
stop so what about um if you had to
start over let's just say you or i or
both of us got canceled or whatever like
we got canceled over this interview or
whatever both of us would would you
start over or would you just that's fine
i'll take my dollars throw it into you
know a dividend stock and just depends i
think it depends on what it would be and
how bad it would be i mean i would hope
that there would be like you're deleted
from youtube it's the scenario you got
deleted
okay just uh you know it's funny i did a
podcast with ryan pineda and he asked me
like if you were not doing youtube what
would you do right now okay and i said
music oh wow i do music okay okay so
really as a passion project or to like
really i can't do anything without the
purpose of making money behind it so i'd
like to find a way to make money from it
good but i would be doing music damn
music and coffee music
yeah the brand survives i do music what
about you if i got canceled yeah well
i'd still have to work i'm not quite at
that point yet where i would just chill
but uh i'd probably reach out to andre
and be like yo andre you need some help
oh find another job okay yeah i'll find
another job or something like that or
just do my own action why didn't you say
kevin well because you got canceled oh
oh oh
yeah because
like i was about to say like if you got
canceled like i could need this more
yeah but like i couldn't do the podcast
with it without you i mean that would be
the thing and then you know i don't know
if you got canceled i would i would
probably i'd call up nate o'brien and
i'd be like please join me he's like nah
sorry man i'm only posting once every
other month yeah
he's got a great lifestyle oh yeah so
we went to vegas with him at this point
years ago was 18 or 19 or something
maybe it was in 2018. uh and uh
i remember walking with him it was ice
cold outside too but he was so happy and
it was just so carefree which was so
wonderful because he had no stress at
all in his life and just uh so yeah you
know i post what i want and i'm like
well what you so you don't have a
schedule no yeah what do you do oh i
just travel with my car and i go places
and do whatever i want yeah and i'm just
like
man i wish i could do that
but but i don't but but you know what
the thing is i don't think you would you
wouldn't be happy with that nate would
hate your life oh he would hate it the
schedule the constant responsibilities
i've seen like what what he's about he
loves the no obligation and i i envy him
too i'm like he has all of his stuff in
it it basically he could fit in the back
of his car and that's it that's all the
stuff he has it's not complicated and
you can go anywhere at any time
but uh i don't think i would be happy
with that of not having that strict
schedule having that obligate like i
like that to to go back to so almost
like a different definition of happiness
for everyone yeah that's interesting
yeah but i think all of us would like to
be nate
um but i don't know if we would be happy
with being nate for more than like a few
days at a time okay i think it's a
different type of happiness because when
i talk to nate
like off camera and everything he is
like you said the most chill person and
he seems so happy and just stress free
at all times but then sometimes i'll
talk to other people like i'll talk to
you off camera and stuff like that and
you're stressed out sometimes oh my god
oh yeah sometimes all of us so like you
could say that every person has their
own idea of what happiness is but i also
think that like like there is a really
like i think there is an objective truth
to
balancing work and life yeah yeah trying
well everything everything's the balance
right right and it's just tough to to
find that balance and also there's
nothing i want to point out uh i wanted
to point out but it was um i think that
it would be really tough for you guys to
get cancelled because i think the
finance be the people that consume
finance content all that they care about
is your credibility
of the credibility of what you're saying
right so like for example if you guys
did like something sketchy like fraud or
you guys were sellouts you guys pumped
something something like that that could
cancel yeah
right like you made a coin
exactly but i think you guys are way too
smart to do something like that
but as far as like saying something
maybe like not so pc or something like
that i honestly think
people would not cancel you because
they're here for the information more
than they're here for like the
personality just in general oh that's an
interesting so pov that's i mean that's
that that makes sense
but you know
but sometimes you don't know exactly
like like seeing uh
ellen you
you haven't seen that that was big
for mistreatment of employees oh
yeah
i never really liked it and she stepped
away from her show i mean she said she
was gonna i'm sure she was gonna do it
anyway at some point but it's like well
if i do it now or five years i'm amazed
now yeah or like the uh i mean i don't
know enough about this to really go deep
in it but even like andrew cuomo like
could you imagine like both of the
cuomo's right like one's got a solid gig
at cnn the other one's got uh uh you
know he's
uh he's he's well in politics and well
established in poland and then just to
go from like and honestly people would
watch andrew cuomo and his coveted
briefings uh during the beginning of the
pandemic i don't know if you guys did
but like march and april and may at the
beginning of the pandemic i remember
lauren and i would be like oh what's
what's andrew cuomo got to say because
like new york was like the epicenter it
was like
i remember when i lived in florida
listening to like the hurricane
forecasters okay it's now category five
it should make landfall at seven a.m and
like getting that that up to the minute
update was always so like oh my gosh
what's going on and i remember watching
him and i thought his briefings were
good i mean obviously now in hindsight
we're like okay some things maybe
weren't the best but um and again i'm
not trying to get political on the
podcast but just to think that you could
be at such a place where people are
watching you and care about what you say
and then literally now
yeah fired from scene but the thing is
it's a herd mentality too it's if
everyone else hates them or her or
whoever it is then you should too
and and and what's what's crazy is it
villainize you if you support them
that's right right but it's it's i've
noticed too and you know this as well on
youtube it's it's if there's good
information or if there's something
positive people won't watch it if it's
negative people will watch it if there's
drama they'll watch it even more
and so some of our most viewed videos
unfortunately they're they're the videos
with drama or they have some sort of
emotional spike in the video it's like
what did this person say to this person
why are they angry why don't they like
this person and it's something that i
think people inherently get really
invested in that that's true and uh
opinions are are really hard to change
like it could be you could have a
positive opinion it's hard to change a
negative opinion about someone that's a
good point so really good point now i
want to jump i want to ask you uh when
are you ever going to go into margin
maybe i'm only asking you because i just
recently went back into march and i feel
bad about it oh i'm so heavy in margin
right now
asmr no no no yeah i was worried about
you for a second because i know you went
you went in margin how much five million
three million in margin right now uh if
i net out cash because i have some cash
at different brokerages i'm about three
and a half three and a half and i knew
that uh why watching your live streams
that you invested like all of your money
during the recent dip yes and then it
kept dipping for those extra two days
and i i could tell like in the back of
your mind you're like oh crap did i just
spend everything a little bit too soon
sure oh yeah uh and then the market just
rebounded sure but uh yeah no i don't
want to mess with it it's just the
stress it's it's just like i don't want
to do that
i would i was could i would go in a
margin to buy like that real estate deal
if i needed to temporarily gladly do
that if i knew that like okay you know
i'll be able to pay it back off and you
know x amount of
months or whatever it could be but that
would be it that's a good point yeah i
uh because now uh i mean the tax bill is
going to be insane i don't even know
what to do yet uh and so i have to pay
off my margin for tax time so that way i
can now go fully in margin again just to
pay my taxes yeah but the taxes are
always an interesting thing especially
in california so you got out of
california lucky dog
one last question please and then we
could turn it on you if you have any
questions for us well
but what are your thoughts in the
metaverse
uh well
uh i think uh
for now we're going to be in this
spectacular phase of ridiculous
speculation
mostly everything's going to be
extremely speculative
there are some really practical
applications in the metaverse that i
think are going to be really cool so for
example jack your dad uh does i'm not
sure if he still does did appraisals
for that was his career and uh
i think it would be phenomenal if
we had like matterport scans of let's
say a property and he could essentially
like teleport or just appear in that
scan of a property with let's say the
listing agent and they could walk around
that property
just wearing like a vr headset and nvr
stuff so it's as if we're having this
conversation but it's all digital but i
can also walk with you around a space so
it's kind of like oh what's what's over
here what's what's over there uh that i
think is going to be our first sort of
practical application of the metaverse
where it's kind of like
going to spaces or inviting people to a
space that could be home appraisals that
could be concerts i think will be very
very popular it could be hey let's visit
the great wall of china i'm never going
to china i think i'm going to get killed
if i go to china i say too much crap
about china in my live streams so
like i reached out to to neo and they're
like hey we'd love to to to like do a
video with you or whatever talking about
neo let's do it in norway
they're a chinese company wow yeah so
anyway so i don't want to go to china
but i want to go to china right and if i
could do that in the metaverse and i'm
at home then it's like hey lauren it's
five o'clock what are we gonna do oh
let's go to the great wall of china
let's go watch a i don't know you know a
chinese show like a performance or
whatever
in the metaverse that i think is
spectacular i think it's gonna go in
that direction i was i thought it was
stupid initially and then and then i
spent that weekend doing research and
afterwards i was like this is going to
change everything and i remember during
covid we would sometimes play those
games on i forget what what that was
called uh whatever game that was called
zoom and then go to that website right
play the game together right but imagine
being able to put on a screen and both
of you are here and we could do this
virtually and it would all be recorded
we could kind of set up our virtual
cameras anywhere any you know the
lighting would be perfect always or to
be able to go into an office and you put
in that headset and your office is there
and everyone's around you is working and
you could share documents
instantaneously so i could see exactly
what you're working on you could see
what i'm working on we could share
um i i think eventually this could be 20
years down the line but eventually i
think office space could be decimated by
this
if eventually you just put on a headset
and you're there and everyone's around
you it's it's gonna well i you know i
think real estate's always going to be a
bit of a local market so like places
like you know by by the beach we're
always going to be you know in in desire
but uh
yeah
that's really interesting because see
one of the problems with office spaces
you want to have this balance between
like having your own like
cubicle like sealed off thing but then
wanting to be with people but the
problem is when you have too much of an
open concept and like you're working on
a project and then every two minutes
somebody comes up to you and talks to
you and like has an opinion or a comment
or a question or whatever now you can't
be productive but if you were in the
metaverse you could probably i'm
guessing just like do not disturb we
should do not disturb voting if you're
like red
you don't you would be right but there
would be like a poke button where if
like you give three pokes to this person
then it's
exactly yeah yeah you only get one of
those uses of right
it's it's brilliant uh i
one it's one of the reasons in in real
estate and i've been really fussy about
real estate uh i only want and people
get mad at me for this but i only want
socal uh and people get mad at me about
this and then like i've considered
austin and florida and maybe i'll expand
in the future but i look at it as like i
just want the mediterranean climate and
i believe that if i buy properties that
are in the mediterranean climate which
is only in seven percent of the world
socal is the only place in the united
states that has the mediterranean
climate then then i
guaranteed have at least a reason people
will always want to move there i'm not
reliant on the ford factory i'm not
reliant on
the office space over there or whatever
i don't i'm reliant on the weather which
this is the only place you can get in
the united states
at what cost if that becomes too
expensive people are going to give that
up oh yeah i mean don't get me wrong
like i was just in uh looking at a
fixer-upper in santa barbara i might
post a video on it but i looked at a
fixer-upper in santa barbara and it was
um 950 thousand dollars for a three and
two eleven hundred square feet tiny
little 1950s cracked foundation total
fixer disaster right nine hundred fifty
thousand dollars for this i get there
it's a circus everybody's got their
homework this is under a million dollars
right and i'm like i think i said this
video like i think this is gonna sell
for like 10.70 or something so i found
out from the listing agent that even she
was blown away she was getting offers
for like 11.50 and i'm like this is
insane like it doesn't even make sense
to try to flip something like this
anymore
uh and so
i do think and so i asked her i go are
these flippers she's like no there's no
margin anymore are they rental investors
she's like no these are just people who
have they want to live there and they
have cash and they have the cash uh and
so uh i do unfortunately think that
because this is a common complaint in
california it's like oh well it's
unaffordable to live here i have to move
i shouldn't have to move is the argument
people make like why do i have to move
and it's like well unfortunately in a
capitalistic society that's the way it
works if a place is really desirable and
people want to live there they're going
to pay for it and if you can't afford it
that means you have to move
and it sucks but i think that's going to
continue happening so i do think that
like socal real estate is a special
investment especially where we're
filming right now in ventura yeah is is
a hidden gem because you are getting the
santa barbara the san diego weather
without the la homelessness you know
what's crazy i never would have said
this about ventura but i i really like
it i knew you would graham jack but you
know what uh when i when i was going to
the operating room every single day
i never would have bought up here ever
because it's too far but with the
shutdowns and like not needing to go
anywhere
i like it like it's the best man part of
me believes that if i could snap my
fingers and turn that house where i have
now in west l.a and get i would get an
even nicer place here
i might do it you know it's it's nice i
i believe it
i believe it now i see it yeah yeah it's
it's uh
i don't know maybe i'm biased living
here but look i grew up in south florida
i i know
florida weather uh i know there are some
wonderful things about florida i feel
like it's a lot more of a free
you can do you could get away with a lot
more everybody's got a gun uh the town i
grew up in was very cowboy everybody had
a horse everybody had also a gun uh and
uh even the police force still had a
mounted unit like a davey florida really
really country so i feel like i grew up
with
cowboys cowboy hats belt buckles i've
got my tesla belt buckle on
uh and boots right
which is very very different from from
california but this little part of
california some people call it ventucky
instead of ventura yes it has a lot more
of that like that cowboy-esqueness
and that freeing feeling so all right
kevin the question everyone is dying to
know the answer to how much money are
you making this year oh man yeah uh well
i wish i had a cpa to give me an exact
uh which that's why we're hiring one in
person there's still so much accounting
to do but uh it's probably going to be
in excess of about 22 this year no yeah
and you're talking are you talking about
stocks
are you counting stocks no no no not
counting stocks like just ordinary
income what how uh well we started doing
uh brand sponsorships now that has
helped a lot because i took a lot of
videos so that's i've noticed almost
every day you do a sponsor out of like
is it one sponsor a day no i mean i
could do three a day because i'm posting
if i'm pushing like videos
i thought you were about to say like 10
to 12 and i was like
that's nuts
i really i was hoping to
to double that what we had last time
that we talked about because last time
it was it was uh it was like how me
kevin makes it was like two million
dollars it was like what that without
one million a month and it was one time
i hit one mill in a month right oh
yeah
have you ever had a three million dollar
month yeah oh
my
god
sorry are you kidding me you know what
sucks kevin honestly we've like secretly
i've always had this i feel like this
bit of like a rivalry with you where i
like i kind of look at i know you look
at what i'm doing i look at what you're
doing we're like how do we one-up each
other
and
i've given up i just seriously man for a
while i
back when you were doing those stimulus
updates jack said graham so you know
kevin's doing like 20 million views a
month i'm like but he's doing five
videos a day yeah i know he was just
totally like i know i can't just you
know do that but you know i'm doing well
this year
oh man it's like so it's like
when we're like this
i could be like all right well i could
compete you know i could push myself
that way when it's like this
so you've done a three million dollar a
month and this is funny because the
first title we did was how meat kevin
makes a million a month the second video
was how meet kevin makes two million a
month
this video homie kevin makes three
million gosh
it's it's that much from well and that
was that was a those were like peak
months that stuff yeah but average but i
guarantee throughout this next year now
that you have the efficiency because
i've been seeing more of the sponsors in
the mid-up that you've been pre-filming
uh if you're doing five videos a day and
you have someone who's really on you
with the sponsors you could have like an
80 to 100 fill rate on your videos with
sponsors that's true i only do a few a
month because
man you go down to two and then you can
have every single video filled with a
sponsor and you'll make so much more
money but i feel like content will be
better yeah but but the issue with kevin
is that uh kevin's so many of them that
he could just like
but your content will be better and
you'll make more money
for like kevin right now like maybe half
your videos are sponsored if that sure
yeah so yeah for me to have half of my
video like the same ratio
i would only have like one every other
gosh
congratulations man that's that's
incredible yeah it's uh it's also a
problem because then i think you you
have brought this up in your videos it's
like that hedonic treadmill yeah it's
like oh now i gotta now i gotta beat
that like now that's the norm
yeah and you know what the thing is uh
too kevin like i your sponsors
um
they like they don't even bother me and
and i worry with my audience too that
they get bothered by sponsorships but i
i see yours and i'm like they've reached
out to me too there's almost all of them
that you've done almost all of them i've
worked with too so i know the talking
points i know you hit i'm like sometimes
your sponsor do you have someone else
scripting them for you uh-huh
that's why
because they're good
they're good sponsorships so they just
give you the ad and you literally just
read it i
like can't stand dealing with any of
that so like i this is why i like having
people in person so there's one person
that's like kevin do this right now
here's the prop
now
film it for me and then he sends it off
for approval puts the little graphic
edits or whatever and then uh then you
know uh
for another video it'd be like okay now
this one's approved here's the link you
have to put in the description here's
the clip
and you how far ahead do you film these
few days four days okay
that's insane kevin congratulations
it's okay it's not okay yes it is okay
man no it's not why
he's your friend
no i am i'm happy for him but like but
usually there's a point where kevin
could get to where i'm like all right i
could get to that too i can't post five
videos today i thought
peace productive in ways that i don't
even know is possible without like
stimulants of some sort you don't i and
i can attest to this kevin will wake up
in the morning at five a.m he'll he'll
stay up until two he'll wake up at five
and be like i have so much energy i'm
just gonna go and run and he'll go on a
run for like several miles come back
it'll be seven a.m he'll take a shower
he'll get a video done like 7 30.
i can't do it
it's gosh all right congratulations you
happy for you kevin but uh
gotta i got some thinking to do that's
so long
well good to end on that okay thank you
so much for coming over kevin it is
awesome to shoot with you also happy
christmas eve merry christmas merry
christmas eve thanks all right so with
that said you guys thanks so much for
watching make sure to subscribe get your
free stock in the description
subscribe to kevin subscribe to kevin
check out his content and his tick talk
and hit the notification bell and with
that said until next time